Tout le reste est sujet à notre interprétation.
L'existence du calcul dépend de notre conscience.
Soit un être conscient effectue le calcul,
soit il possède une machine dont le résultat doit être interprété comme un calcul.
Ça ne veut pas dire que le calcul soit arbitraire.
J'ai investi beaucoup d'argent dans cette machine.
Mais nous confondons en permanence
l'objectivité et la subjectivité qui déterminent la réalité
avec l'objectivité et la subjectivité qui déterminent une affirmation scientifique.
Le point principal de cette partie de mon discours, c'est ceci :
on peut avoir une science complètement objective,
une science où l'on peut affirmer des vérités objectives,
sur un sujet dont l'existence est subjective,
qui n'existe que dans le cerveau humain,
et consiste en différents états subjectifs où l'on a connaissance de quelque chose,
où l'on ressent, ou bien l'on est sensible à quelque chose.
Argumenter qu'on ne peut pas avoir une science objective de la conscience
du fait que la conscience est subjective et la science objective, c'est jouer sur les mots.
C'est un mauvais jeu de mots sur l'objectivité et la subjectivité.
On peut affirmer des vérités objectives
dans un domaine qui est subjectif par nature,
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que font les neurologues.
Ils ont des malades qui souffrent réellement,
et ils tentent d'en faire une science objective.
Bon, je vous ai promis de réfuter toutes les affirmations de ces gens,
et il ne me reste plus énormément de temps,
mais laissez-moi en réfuter encore quelques unes.
Je vous ai dit que le béhaviorisme devrait être considéré
comme la plus grande honte de notre culture intellectuelle,
car c'est une théorie qu'on peut réfuter en un instant.
Ainsi, nos états mentaux seraient similaires à notre comportement ?
Eh bien, pensez à la différence qu'il y a entre ressentir une douleur
et avoir un comportement douloureux.
Je ne vais pas vous faire la démonstration de ce qu'est un comportement douloureux,
mais je peux vous assurer que je n'ai mal nulle part en ce moment.
C'est donc une erreur manifeste. Pourquoi ont-ils fait cette erreur ?
Là où ils se sont trompés — et vous pouvez relire
ce qu'ils ont écrit à ce sujet, c'est répété encore et encore —
c'est qu'ils se sont dit qu'admettre l'existence irréductible
de la conscience revenait à abandonner la science.
Abandonner les 300 ans de progrès de l'humanité
et l'espoir humain, et tout le reste.
Et le message que j'aimerais que vous reteniez aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'il est primordial que l'on reconnaisse la conscience
comme un phénomène authentiquement biologique,
qui peut être analysé scientifiquement
comme n'importe quel autre phénomène biologique,
ou, à cet égard, comme tout le reste de la science.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)